nouveau numéro de reporter plus le
magazine de reportage long format de la
rédaction et aujourd'hui c'est une
enquête de près de deux ans que nous
allons vous présenter la toute première
réalisée par la nouvelle cellule
investigation de France 24 les nouvelles
technologies envahissent nos vies pour
le meilleur et parfois pour le pire
parmi ces nouvelles technologies la
reconnaissance faciale dans les rues des
grandes villes de plus en plus de
caméras de surveillance connectée à des
bases de données sont capables grâce à
l'intelligence artificielle d'identifier
précisément les personnes filmées
identité sexe âge et parfois bien plus
lorsqu'il s'agit de reconnaître l'auteur
d'un crime ou d'un délit on peut trouver
normal l'utilisation de cette
technologie mais que se passe-t-il
lorsque la reconnaissance faciale tombe
dans de mauvaises mains si elle est au
service d'une dictature qui cherche à
contrôler sa population ou de groupes
d'intérêts économiques ou politiques
l'un des plus importants acteurs sur ce
secteur de la reconnaissance faciale a
pour nom cleview entreprise ayant pignon
sur rue aux États-Unis mais ces méthodes
sont très critiquées car la manière dont
les view constitue sa base de données en
récupérant sur les réseaux sociaux sans
aucune autorisation les photos de tout
un chacun pose de sérieux problèmes
d'éthique vos visages sont à nous c'est
une enquête exclusive long format signée
Jessica le masurier et Roméo Langlois
pour France 24
[Musique]
la reconnaissance faciale
c'est comme tout ce qui est
technologique ça nous facilite le boulot
[Musique]
quand j'ai commencé on n'avait pas de
caméra embarquée on n'avait pas de
centre de contrôle du crime en temps
réel ni de caméra de surveillance
avant quand personne n'avait rien vu ou
entendu il était impossible d'avoir la
description d'un véhicule d'une personne
ou d'un criminel
[Musique]
pour moi c'est le centre névralgique de
la police de Miami c'est ici que l'on
contrôle nos caméras de sécurité
on fait tourner nos logiciels de
reconnaissance faciale nos lecteurs de
plaques d'immatriculation tout ce qui
peut aider nos officiers sur le terrain
[Musique]
à l'heure où je vous parle on a 575
caméras et ça ne cesse d'augmenter
cette caméra est placée sur le toit de
l'hôtel intercontinentaire
et je vais vous montrer la puissance du
zoom
regardez celle-ci
ils vendent de la drogue à côté d'une
épicerie comme si c'était des bonbons
vous voyez la drogue
mais en zoom notre caméra peut voir tout
ce qui se passe là-bas
on voit bien les sachets on voit tout ce
qu'ils vendent
tellement de choses vous savez
[Musique]
un braquage de voiture le criminel a
écrasé le propriétaire de la voiture
puis il s'est enfui le propriétaire du
véhicule est décédé sur place
dans document
é grâce à claireview
clear view Hai pour intelligence
artificielle
ce logiciel permet d'identifier un
suspect en quelques clics à partir d'une
simple photo
claireview cherche sur une base de
données colossale des milliards de
visages collectés sur Internet
justice
c'est très simple à reconnaissance
faciale il en a une image de quelqu'un
on l'a soumet à l'ordinateur et on
obtient des photos qui correspondent
d'identifier une personne avec la
reconnaissance faciale c'est une affaire
de minutes de jour pour peu qu'elles
soient en photo sur les réseaux sociaux
Instagram une partie des images de clear
view proviennent des réseaux sociaux
pour les agents une mine d'information
sur les suspects leurs complices et
leurs proches
clairview c'est le deuxième logiciel de
reconnaissance faciale le plus efficace
au monde après celui du Parti communiste
chinois mais celui-là on en veut pas
la reconnaissance faciale évoque le pire
du modèle chinois
la surveillance de masse
des caméras partout des habitants
identifiés en temps réel suivi pas à pas
et même noté par l'intelligence
artificielle
[Musique]
les policiers disent faire de cleview en
usage responsable pas de reconnaissance
faciale en temps réel
il se contenterait d'identifier des
suspects après coup en comparant des
images de surveillance à la gigantesque
base de données de claireview
pour y avoir accès la police de Miami P1
abonnement de 47000 dollars par an
[Musique]
clairview provient d'une société fondée
en 2017 à New York et qui s'appelait
Smart shaker
en quelques années il est devenue
l'entreprise de reconnaissance faciale
la plus controversée de la planète
sur son site clear view revendique
qu'une base de données de 20 milliards
d'images la plus grande collection de
visages au monde
des clients respectables les agences de
sécurité américaine
et une mission d'utilité publique
combattre le crime
[Musique]
clairview participe même à l'effort de
guerre ukrainien depuis le début du
conflit
son utilisation exacte n'est pas claire
les forces de Kiev s'en serviraient
entre autres pour démasquer les espions
russes
qui portaient des uniformes Ukrainiens
pour se dissimuler
à présent les Ukrainiens n'ont qu'à
sortir leur téléphone le pointer sur eux
alors ils peuvent dire non tu n'es pas
Youri de loubov tu es Dimitri de
Vladivostok ils savent exactement qui
ils sont grâce à la reconnaissance
faciale et à l'intelligence artificielle
Richard Clark c'est de quoi il parle il
a fait une partie de sa carrière à la
Maison Blanche dans l'antitorisme
lors des attentats du 11 septembre il
était en première ligne
ensuite il est passé dans le privé
l'un de mes rôles au comité consultatif
c'est de m'assurer qu'il ne fasse rien
qu'il soit contre l'éthique ou du moral
et nous sommes très bonjour sur ce point
nous nous vendrons pas à certains pays
nous permettront pas qu'il soit mal
utilisé
le PDG de clear view s'appelle one
tentat c'est un informaticien australien
il dit descendre de la royauté
vietnamienne et avoir émigré aux
États-Unis à 19 ans
aujourd'hui il vit à New York
programmation depuis que je suis enfant
au lieu d'aller à l'école je restais à
la maison et je regardais des vidéos du
mit ensuite je suis parti m'installer
dans la Silicon Valley je l'appelle le
Hollywood des nerfs les meilleurs
programmeurs veulent tous aller là-bas
je vais faire une démo sur votre visage
ça vous va souriez
nous avons rencontré one durant l'été
c'est en train de chercher de passer en
revue toutes ces photos en ligne
vous arrivez à trouver quelque chose
c'est une photo de groupe sur Instagram
c'est incroyable je savais jamais vu
cette photo avant
le secret du logiciel explique son
inventeur c'est qu'il a été entraîné sur
des milliards de visages
ça fonctionne grâce à un réseau de
neurones c'est une forme d'intelligence
artificielle qui est entraînée sur des
millions de visages les anciens
algorithmes mesuraient la distance entre
les yeux le nez et la bouche mais un
réseau de neurones est entraîné sur
tellement de photos différentes qui
devient très robuste donc les gens
peuvent charger des photos prises sous
différents angles sous diverses lumières
à des âges différents avec des lunettes
ou de la barbe le réseau cherche sur des
pages web des sites judiciaires les
réseaux sociaux tout ce qui est
publiquement accessible il n'y a rien de
privé
collecter des photos sur internet n'est
pas illégal aux États-Unis
clear view a d'abord opéré dans l'ombre
jusqu'à ce qu'un spécialiste de la tech
révèle son existence
je m'appelle Freddie Martinez je suis
chercheur au project ongoven
mantoversight j'enquête notamment sur
les outils de surveillance utilisés par
la police et dans le cadre de ce projet
j'ai fait de nombreuses demandes de
dossiers publics concernant la
reconnaissance faciale et c'est comme ça
que j'ai découvert l'existence de clear
view
le droit américain autorise les citoyens
à accéder au document public Freddy
obtient une copie des échanges entre
claireview et diverses polices et un
texte à dire son attention
ce document a été rédigé par les avocats
de kerview et en gros il établitent les
gens n'ont aucun droit sur leurs images
et que la compagnie peut les récolter
pour les revendre d'une certaine manière
la compagnie crée des dossiers en ligne
au fil des années
c'est à ce moment là qu'on a contacté le
New York Times et c'est devenu la base
de l'enquête
en janvier 2020 le journal révèle
l'existence de clear view et de son
trombinoscope mondial
ce café clear view à ma connaissance
aucune autre compagnie aux États-Unis ne
voudrait le faire
car balayer internet à la recherche de
milliers de photos sur les réseaux
sociaux les sites d'informations locales
les sites de leurs employeurs partout
c'est trop controversé et abusif
cette base de données est rassemblée à
l'insu de tous sans le consentement des
personnes qui ont leur visage dedans
[Musique]
au nom du droit à la vie privée l'Union
américaine pour les libertés civiles
attaquent clear view en justice
fait le tour des médias pour défendre
son application
devient mondiale autour des activités de
clear view entreprise très discrète
à des polices étrangères et même à des
entreprises privées
l'ombre de l'ultra-droite plane sur la
société
pour retracer les débuts de clear view
nous avons rencontré cet homme
l'investisseur Charles Johnson alias
Chuck
New York a vraiment changé
à vraiment changer il y a beaucoup plus
de vaguement maintenant je sais pas si
comment dire en français
[Musique]
dit avoir joué un rôle clé dans les
débuts de la société
one tentat était alors son ami
en mars 2023 Chuck a porté plainte
contre clairview pour rupture de contrat
bon club
[Musique]
Johnson se passionne pour la biométrie
c'est des tracteurs voient en lui un
agitateur d'extrême droite
[Musique]
en 2015 après une série de tweets
racistes son compte Twitter a été
supprimé
[Musique]
à 33 ans chuck est déjà riche
et il connaît beaucoup de monde
[Musique]
notamment à la droite du parti
républicain
[Musique]
le voici en 2016 avec le sulfureux Steve
Bannon
banane
le chef de campagne de Donald Trump
[Musique]
pendant des années Chuck a écrit pour
bright bar news un média de droite dur
alors dirigé par banane
[Musique]
choc affirme qu'il a été écarté de clear
view mais qu'il a encore des ambitions
pour la société
d'après lui l'application devrait
intéresser le marché européen
vous avez ce problème aussi non tous ces
migrants tous ces gens là qui viennent
de Syrie et il y en aura d'autres
ils ne peuvent pas tous venir en France
en Allemagne aux États-Unis il faudra
bien trouver une solution à ce problème
c'est là que la reconnaissance faciale
pour être utile
ne sont pas si malheureux que ça pas ils
sont pauvres en comparaison à d'autres
et donc ils ont des identités on
pourrait vérifier qui est qui
est une figure très menaçante acide il
cherche à être le plus terrifiant et
menaçant possible particulièrement avec
ceux qui ne considèrent comme inférieur
femme les personnes de couleur celles
qui ont des origines juives toute
personne qui n'est pas un homme blanc et
hétérosexuel
j'ai travaillé avec Chuck pendant 4 ans
et demi il essayait en permanence
d'impressionner son monde de démontrer
qu'il était puissant et avait des amis
influents
cette femme est une repentie de l'ultra
droite
elle a côtoyé les suprémacistes blancs
et connaît leurs secrets
aujourd'hui elle vit caché
nous l'appellerons Artémis
j'ai peur de révéler mon identité
parce que j'ai reçu beaucoup de menaces
quand j'ai commencé à m'éloigner de
l'extrême droite
Artémis a rencontré les principaux
cybers militants de l'ultra-droite
elle dépeint des individus dangereux qui
sous couverts du Mont Noir prêchent la
haine en ligne
quand on les voit ils font comme si de
rien n'était
ce n'est pas facile d'y voir clair dans
leur jeu
il poste des mêmes du genre péter la
grenouille ils me disent hello
et en même temps il parle d'exterminer
les Juifs
[Applaudissements]
des années 20 la suprématie blanche et
il dit ajoute le nouveau terrorisme
d'extrême droite en ligne
je ne sais pas comment chuck est devenu
aussi riche je sais qu'il a des
connexions avec des milliards puissants
son réseau Chuck dit d'avoir mis à
disposition de washton that le PDG de
cleview pour trouver les premiers
investisseurs
j'ai présenté One a beaucoup de mes
contacts ils ont trouvé qu'il était un
brillant technicien mais un piètre homme
d'affaires alors je leur disais ne vous
inquiétez pas sage m'en occupe on a
récolté de l'argent pour la société qui
a commencé à avoir du succès c'était une
époque triomphante
et se développe pendant les années 30
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
Cleveland était 2016 Donald Trump
remporte la primaire du Parti
républicain
[Musique]
parmi ces supporters Chuck Johnson et
wenton
[Applaudissements]
ce jour-là un grand nom de la Silicon
Valley prend la parole d'accord
le milliardaire Peter till qui deviendra
l'un des premiers investisseurs de
clerview
affirme que Cleveland il a présenté one
Town tactile
et comme je le connaissais j'ai dit ok
organisons ça je lui ai dit one
travaille sur des trucs intéressants la
reconnaissance faciale ce genre de
choses Peter a trouvé ça cool on a
beaucoup parlé du politiquement correct
du communisme
[Applaudissements]
c'est l'un des fondateurs de Paypal au
côté d'Elon musk on est 90 il crée
avec Elon Musk ce système de paiement
qu'on connaît tous
on connaît la carrière de d'Elon musk
qui est beaucoup plus public petersie il
est bien plus discret
avec les attentats du 11 septembre la
carrière de Peter t-il se précise
l'Amérique se lance dans un programme
d'espionnage planétaire
c'est le début de la Guerre mondiale
contre le terrorisme plus rien n'échappe
ou presque aux antennes de la NSA
l'agence d'espionnage électronique
Peter t-il fondent alors pas lentilles
un puissant logiciel de traitement et
d'analyse de données
[Musique]
les premiers clients de palantir les
agences de renseignement américaines
[Musique]
la raison pour laquelle on a fondé par
c'est parce que la NSA se lancer dans
cette gigantesque programme de
surveillance de masse aux quatre coins
de la terre le problème c'est que ça
produit une quantité astronomique de
données et que pour faire sens de cette
quantité astronomique de données il faut
un nouveau type de logiciel ça sera pas
lundi
ralentir c'est le logiciel Big Brother
alors quand on lui propose d'investir
dans la reconnaissance faciale le patron
de palantir est tenté
dans un écosystème de l'industrie de la
surveillance qui est la plus performante
de la planète
Peter till incarne l'aile droite de la
Silicon Valley
un courant autoritaire qui place les
algorithmes au-dessus de la démocratie
n'a pas répondu à nos demandes
d'interview la grande vision de Peter
till sur la gouvernance des hommes c'est
vraiment un troupeau de moutons
pour lesquelles il faut disposer de
chiens qui vont guider le troupeau et on
va soi-même en tant que berger parce
qu'évidemment une en haut de la pyramide
pouvoir diriger les chiens c'est grosso
modo sa vision de la société
fin 2016
Donald Trump était lu président
[Musique]
elle reste sous les radars
en Europe à la différence des États-Unis
la reconnaissance faciale est
strictement encadrée
ces promeneurs ne sont pas pour autant
protégés ils l'ignorent mais leur visage
figure peut-être dans la base de données
de clients
[Musique]
pour la première fois en janvier 2020
dans un article de New York Times et moi
j'avais été
très interloquée par cette société parce
que c'était la première fois qu'on
entendait parler d'une société qui
faisait de la reconnaissance faciale qui
avait composé sa propre base de données
Zoé vilain est la première française à
sonner l'alarme
pour créer sa base de données clear view
a conçu des algorithmes capables
d'aspirer quotidiennement des millions
de photos sur Internet
une pratique controversée le strapping
le scriber c'est un outil automatique
qui est lancé sur tous les sites
internet du monde entier et qui permet
de brasser les photos à grande échelle
toutes les photos que vous avez mis sur
vos profils facebook sur Twitter sur
Instagram ils sont allés collecter ça en
masse et ils ont enregistré ça de leur
côté peut-être que vous avez supprimé
les photos depuis de votre Instagram de
votre Twitter etc mais eux ont fait une
copie entre temps c'est à dire qu'ils
ont fait ça mais sur des quantités
astronomiques
c'est à ce moment-là que moi je
m'interroge et je me demande si les
données personnelles des Français donc
des photographies de français ou même
plus largement d'Européens aurait été
collectés par la société clear view
le droit européen autorise chaque
citoyen a demandé un organisme s'il
détient des données le concernant
au nom de ce droit d'accès Zoé écrit à
qui review après de nombreuses relances
elle reçoit enfin quatre photos dont une
qu'elle n'avait jamais vu
la photo numéro 2
c'est une mémoire d'internet c'est une
photographie qui n'est plus en ligne de
moi mais que eux ont bien conservé dans
leur base de données ils ont
connaissance d'articles dans lesquels
j'apparais en photographie dont moi-même
je n'avais jamais eu connaissance et
donc j'ai décidé à ce moment-là de
saisir la CNIL
la CNIL c'est la Commission Informatique
et Liberté un organisme chargé de faire
appliquer le rgpd le règlement européen
sur la protection des données
les données biométriques ont un statut
particulier puisque ce sont des données
sensibles c'est lié à votre
plus intime c'est à dire vous votre
corps votre visage et dont le traitement
doit répondre à des conditions
particulières le traitement en fait on
est sur un principe d'interdiction de
traitement des données et avec un régime
un régime d'exception
après 6 mois d'enquête la CNIL accuse
qui review d'avoir violé le RG
P principal grief
avoir collecté des données biométriques
sans le consentement des intéressés
sommet d'effacer ses photos de citoyens
européens
clairview ne répond pas interview estime
que le rgpd ne lui est pas applicable
qu'il n'a pas d'établissement en Europe
et qu'il ne propose pas son service à
des entreprises européennes le dialogue
qui est assez peu constructif et
productif
fin 2022 la CNIL inflige à la société de
New Yorkaise une amende de 20 millions
d'euros clairview refuse de payer
[Musique]
lors de notre rencontre wanted that n'a
pas souhaité commenter les inquiétudes
européennes
notre équipe de juristes étudie ses
plaintes tout ce que je peux vous dire
c'est que c'est de l'information
publique
sur les réseaux sociaux vous pouvez
choisir un profil public ou privé si
vous décidez d'avoir votre profil public
alors par définition tout le monde peut
le voir
c'est un peu comme marché dans la rue
si vous marchez dans la rue en public
les gens peuvent vous photographier et
ensuite utilisez la photo
[Musique]
au pays des Gafa mais du business roi
aucune loi fédérale ne protège les
données personnelles aucune n'encadre la
reconnaissance faciale
[Musique]
vous voulez en savoir plus sur la
reconnaissance faciale bonne journée
à Times Square le nipidy la police de
New York a des yeux partout
[Applaudissements]
une deux trois quatre cinq six sept
c'était énorme et en haut des bâtiments
il y en a d'autres
[Applaudissements]
25500 caméras de la police dans toute la
ville et elles utilisent la
reconnaissance faciale et encore il ne
s'agit que de celle-ci a pu lister
selon eux cette technologie est loin
d'être infaillible surtout quand elle
cible des personnes de couleur
ça peut mal identifier les gens donc
certains se font arrêter alors qu'ils
n'ont rien fait
il y a des gens qui ont été arrêtés sur
la seule base de la reconnaissance
faciale
bien sûr plusieurs fois un homme dans le
New Jersey a été détenu pendant des
semaines à cause de la reconnaissance
faciale et il n'avait jamais été près de
la scène du crime à Détroit aussi un
homme a été arrêté encore un faux
positif
dans tous ces cas d'arrestation ils
utilisent des technologies de
reconnaissance faciale ancienne et en
plus il y a eu très peu d'erreurs
comparées au nombre d'enquêtes résolues
pour les militants la reconnaissance
faciale menace aussi les libertés
politiques
c'est l'outil idéal pour l'autoritarisme
parce qu'en démocratie si on laisse le
gouvernement suivre tout le monde à la
trace alors la liberté d'expression
d'association de religions tout cela
passe à la trappe
la menace c'est concrétisée en 2020 lors
du mouvement Black lives matter contre
les violences policières déclenchées
après la mort de George Floyd les Noirs
américains descendent dans la rue
des manifestations dégénères
[Musique]
dans certains états la police aurait
utilisé la reconnaissance faciale pour
identifier des manifestants
et susceptible d'entraîner des abus
qu'elle ne devrait absolument pas être à
la disposition de la Police
et encore moins pour identifier des
manifestants même si un délit a été
commis si les manifestants savent qu'ils
risquent d'être immédiatement identifié
et poursuivi par la police cela revient
à les dissuader d'exercer leurs droits
constitutionnels à manifester
[Musique]
a porté plainte contre la police de New
York
il l'accuse d'avoir utilisé la
reconnaissance faciale pour l'identifier
puis pour l'intimité
[Musique]
je pense que Claire view a été utilisé
contre moi j'étais très actif dans le
milieu militant ici à New York et je
pense qu'ils ont essayé de me réduire au
silence
[Musique]
des Rick Ingram a activement pris part
aux manifestations de 2020
au point de se retrouver wanted
recherché par la police de New York
il est accusé d'avoir assourdi un
policier avec un mégaphone
[Musique]
trois semaines après cet appel à témoin
d'Eric et chez lui quand le nwaipidy
débarque en force
ça a commencé à 7h du matin il y avait
30 policiers autour de mon appartement
ils avaient des béliers devant ma porte
il y avait des drones dehors avec des
caméras sur les fenêtres des tireurs
d'élite sur les toits j'ai pensé que je
pourrais être tué si je quittais mon
appartement
ce jour-là la police n'a aucun mandat
d'arrêt
terre est dans son appartement Derrick
appelle Alex sur les réseaux sociaux
des militants arrivent en masse
[Applaudissements]
sous la pression la police va en
retraite
Derrick ne sera jamais inculpé
toutes les charges ont été abandonnées
dans l'année qui a suivi et moi j'ai
porté plainte contre la police de New
York
[Musique]
dans sa plainte il accuse la police
d'avoir utilisé la reconnaissance
faciale à ses dépens
[Musique]
pendant l'opération des journalistes ont
pu capturer cette image
sur un document policier une photo de
Derrick
la même que celle diffusée par le
noypidy dans son appel à témoin
elle provient du compte Instagram de
Derrick
[Musique]
il y a aussi ces quelques mots
section d'identification faciale
[Musique]
je pense qu'ils ont utilisé les caméras
de surveillance pour ensuite aller sur
les réseaux sociaux et trouver des
correspondances avec les vidéos de ce
jour-là et une fois qu'ils ont fait ça
ils ont pu trouver exactement où j'étais
et où je résidais
dans cet email envoyé un journaliste
local la police new-yorkaise admet avoir
utilisé la reconnaissance faciale dans
cette enquête
aucune précision sur le logiciel employé
Derrick suspecte clear view mais n'en a
pas la preuve
la police de New York n'a jamais reconnu
utilisée clairview
mais une ONG a pu se procurer deux ans
de correspondance entre la société et le
nwaipidy
des centaines d'e-mails
ils prouvent qu'au moins jusqu'en 2020
de nombreux agents utilisaient
allègrement l'application controversée
un peu partout la signature de one town
that
mais aussi celle de son associé un
certain Richard Schwartz cofondateur de
clients
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
Richard Schwartz est un homme discret
sur internet très peu de photos de lui
il a pourtant joué un rôle majeur à New
York
dans les années 90 il fut l'un des
principaux conseillers du maire Rudolf
Giuliani
Giuliani l'homme qui a réduit le crime
grâce à la tolérance zéro
et inauguré à New York claire de la
vidéo surveillance
Giuliani l'avocat et a mis intime de
Donald Trump
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
Richard Schwarz a refusé de nous parler
selon nos sources il a utilisé son
réseau pour introduire clear view auprès
du andwide
et là encore
Chuck assure que c'est lui qui l'a fait
entrer dans clairview
s
de droite à New York vous savez à New
York rien avant si on n'a pas un vieux
juif dans l'équipe
dans sa plainte déposée en mars 2023
Chuck affirme que lui-même wanted et
Richard Schwarz ont ensemble fondé la
société mais qu'il a été trahi et écarté
de clairview
j'ai compris qu'il voulait garder
l'argent que j'avais levé me mettre sur
la touche mon sentiment c'est qu'il vous
laisse débarrasser de moi j'étais un
problème pour eux
mais ce n'est pas la version de one
tonton
que répondez-vous à ces affirmations
a été fondée par moi-même et mon
partenaire Richard Schwartz qui est de
confession juive nous avons démarré
cette compagnie pour aider les forces de
police dans un premier temps nous avons
développé cette technologie mais tout ça
est entièrement faux mais avez-vous été
en affaires avec Charlton
mais il n'est pas co-fondateur de la
société il n'est pas un employé ni
membre du conseil d'administration ou
investisseurs et il ne l'a jamais été et
c'est tout ce que j'ai à vous dire à ce
sujet
c'est triste de voir quelqu'un mentir
pour de l'argent pathétique très
américain aussi en un sens peut-être
qu'il s'assimile
Chuck nous a envoyé deux vidéos du temps
one et lui était ami
et voici dans un stand de tir en
Californie
[Musique]
une chanson qui s'amuse détruites
racistes de Chuck
[Musique]
dans l'assistance des propos antisémites
une fête pro Trump à New York
des membres des prout boys un groupe
d'extrême droite
et à leurs côtés le PDG de claireview
vous partagez leurs idées politiques
absolument pas je ne suis ni en
nationaliste blonde ni en suprématiste
blanc je ne suis même pas blanc qui
review n'est pas une compagnie à
motivation politique
je pense qu'on est bon
après ces questions s'achève de presse
nous menace si nous diffusons cette
partie de l'interview nous aurons
affaire à l'avocat de clients
Artemis la repenti à elle aussi croisé
le chemin de one
j'ai
rencontrés en présence de suprémacistes
blancs j'ai toujours rencontré dans ce
cadre-là même si je comprends
qu'aujourd'hui il essaye de se refaire
une réputation auprès du public
les racines extrémistes de one n'ont
jamais été reconnues et c'est très
dérangeant quand on sait qu'il travaille
sous contrat avec au moins 600
départements de police qui n'ont aucun
compte à rendre aux États-Unis
n'est pas coté en bourse et la
composition de son capital est opaque
voilà trois ans que Jack Paulson tente
d'en percer les mystères
la valeur de Claire view a été estimée à
130 millions de dollars
actuelles mais pas plus de 250 millions
son ONG enquête sur les liens entre les
entreprises de technologie et les
organes de sécurité
Jack a pu se procurer des contrats entre
clear view et le FBI
le ministère de la Justice
ou celui de la défense
[Musique]
cette somme de une certaine manière ce
que vous voyez dans les rapports du
gouvernement n'est que la partie émergée
de l'iceberg
clairs pour vendre directement au
service de police dans tout le pays et
franchement c'est plus difficile à
tracer
en fouillant dans les contrats publics
Jack a pu confirmer que le principal
client de clerview c'est la police aux
frontières
l'une de ses missions lutter contre
l'immigration illégale
du monde entier et qu'il y a la photo
d'un immigrant aux États-Unis alors la
police aux frontières pourra
t'identifier cette personne et si elle
n'a pas ses papiers la déporter
[Musique]
sur l'un des contrats entre clear view
et la police aux frontières Jack a
trouvé cette phrase
de chip les moutons détestent le chien
du berger jusqu'à ce qu'il se retrouve
au milieu des loups
[Musique]
tombent des chiens de berger et des
loups et récurrent dans les cercles
nationalistes aux États-Unis
ça signifie ce que l'on peut critiquer
ce que la police aux frontières fait ou
ce que clear view fait jusqu'à ce qu'un
loup autrement dit un criminel vous
attaque et là vous retournez en courant
vers les chambres berger
[Musique]
la Californie a interdit à sa police
d'employer la reconnaissance faciale
[Musique]
mais les agences fédérales comme la
police aux frontières ont le droit de
l'utiliser
[Musique]
sans papier c'est constamment essayé de
survivre de joindre les deux bouts de se
débrouiller pour aller à l'école
trouver un travail d'essayer d'avoir une
vie tout simplement
je m'appelle Rena Maldonado j'ai 29 ans
et je suis chef d'entreprise ici en
Californie
avait 6 ans quand sa mère a quitté le
Mexique avec elle pour s'installer aux
États-Unis
à force de travail elle a pu monter ce
restaurant
depuis son adolescence elle se bat pour
les droits des travailleurs immigrés
cette vidéo c'est une manifestation
organisée en 2013 pour alerter sur les
expulsions qui avaient lieu sous Obama
[Musique]
avant Reina n'hésitez pas à publier ce
type de vidéo sur les réseaux sociaux
depuis qui review elle fait profil bas
j'ai arrêté d'utiliser Facebook je
partage très peu sur Instagram et je ne
suis plus active sur Twitter
une fois que j'ai commencé à comprendre
client
avec un groupe d'avocats elle a attaqué
clairview en justice devant une cour de
Californie ils accusent la société
d'aider le gouvernement à surveiller
migrants et activistes
car c'est une manière de contrôler et de
manipuler la société et son
fonctionnement
ils veulent nous intimider nous faire
peur ils veulent vendre nos informations
à des personnes qui ont le contrôle et
pourront utiliser ces données contre
nous
[Musique]
le marché mondial de la surveillance
pèse des centaines de milliards de
dollars
ce jour-là se tient à New York la
conférence internationale sur la
sécurité
et les dernières innovations sont à
l'honneur
[Musique]
elle regarde le vin elle prend une
bouteille
et voilà elle la met dans le sac on a
résolu ce problème en quelques secondes
évidemment clear view est présent
et one tentat tombe bien nous avons
encore des questions
[Musique]
bonjour ça va et les affaires ça va bien
merci combien d'images avez-vous
maintenant dans votre base de données 30
milliards maintenant
où en est votre projet de collecter tous
les visages du monde
vous savez chaque photo peut nous aider
à résoudre un crime mais on ne donne pas
d'interview bonne journée
mais pourquoi pourquoi vous êtes si
contrarié
parlé du rôle de votre technologie en
Ukraine
en Ukraine
mais aussi dans le golfe Persique
fin 2022 lors d'un procès à Londres
l'avocat de clear view a révélé que
l'application était notamment utilisée
aux Émirats arabes unis
[Musique]
les Émirats un petit pays richissime
grâce à ses réserves de gaz
9 millions d'habitants dont 8 millions
d'étrangers
sont là pour travailler et n'obtiendront
jamais la nationalité
une monarchie absolue alliée à
l'Occident
nul ne s'y risque à critiquer la famille
régnante
certains disent que les Émirats ont un
gouvernement très répressifs ceux qui
dis cela n'y sont jamais allés ce n'est
pas un gouvernement massivement
répressif ce n'est juste pas une
démocratie et je le répète tous les pays
n'ont pas à être des démocraties
de millions par an aux États-Unis pour
laver leur réputation ils ne veulent pas
que l'on pense aux violations des droits
humains ils ne veulent pas que l'on
parle des détentions illégales
d'universitaires étrangers tout ce
qu'ils veulent c'est que l'on parle de
Fly Emirates et des aspects positifs du
pays
je ne pense pas que les Émirats soient
autre chose qu'une force de paix de
stabilité et de progresser
les Émirats sont un gros client pour les
sociétés d'armement occidentales
[Musique]
ce jour là à Abu Dhabi le salon
international de la défense basse son
plan
gros contrat à la clé
et depuis 2020 ils ont un nouvel allié
de poids
l'État d'Israël
pionnier en matière de reconnaissance
faciale
les deux pays ont loué une alliance
stratégique contre leur ennemi commun la
République islamique d'Iran
nous sont fiers d'être là grâce aux
accords de pays d'Abraham en ce sont en
sécurité les autorités sont très
aimables
[Musique]
les Émirats ont multiplié les accords de
coopération technologique avec Israël
[Musique]
en matière d'intelligence artificielle
et de reconnaissance faciale ils sont
désormais à la pointe
avec la reconnaissance faciale on peut
retrouver n'importe qui n'importe où
un geste banal
[Applaudissements]
c'est un peu Big Brother ils essaient de
tout contrôler aux Émirats j'appelle ça
une cage dorée
en 2012
pour avoir réclamé des réformes il
risquait la prison
ici il y a des caméras partout dans
chaque rue
aux Émirats tout le monde est suivi cela
répond une forme de peur au sein de la
population
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on va pas s'arrêter là notre communauté
ne laissera pas sans rien faire vendre
nos données biométriques
faire batteur ou le vent en poupe état
après état le droit à l'avortement
recule
c'est manifestants new yorkaise
redoutent que l'intelligence
artificielle ne soit utilisée contre
elle
[Musique]
la reconnaissance faciale et les caméras
de surveillance pourrait être utilisés
pour contrôler les femmes
les femmes qui vont dans une clinique
d'avortement craignent d'être identifié
même si elle porte un masque ou un voile
la rapidité avec laquelle cette
technologie évolue est effrayante
vous avez lu 1984
j'ai lu 35 pages du livre mais je pense
qu'on vit dans un monde très différent
de 1984 aujourd'hui
il s'inquiète d'un programme de
recherche du FBI et du Pentagone qui
pourrait servir à identifier en temps
réel les citoyens américains avec des
caméras et des drones
nous avons de nombreuses inquiétudes
quant aux usages de la reconnaissance
faciale mais ça c'est le cauchemar cela
commence à ressembler à ce qui se passe
dans certains pays totalitaire
les personnes qui se comportent bien
n'ont pas à 5e année
doit des dizaines de millions d'euros
d'amende à des pays étrangers
et encore des procès en cours aux
États-Unis
et d'autres juridictions ont interdit à
la police d'utiliser clerviews
seront régulièrement en Ukraine il parle
d'ouvrir un bureau dans le pays en
guerre
[Musique]
Chuck lui jure qu'il n'est pas raciste
il dit même soutenir aujourd'hui le
président démocrate Joe Biden
ce qui m'intéresse dans le futur c'est
l'utilisation de la génétique pour
prédire le visage mais on en a encore
très loin
en attendant l'issue de son procès
contre clairview Chuck a de nouveaux
projets
étrie j'ai plusieurs sociétés ont
construit une grosse base de données
génétiques un jour je pense les
États-Unis est la plupart des
gouvernements auront un dossier avec
l'ADN de tout le monde la CIA c'est
toujours intéressée à la biométrie
au terme de notre enquête plusieurs
questions sont restées sans réponse
celles notamment d'éventuelles liens
entre clear view et la plus secrète des
agences américaines
nous avons contacté la CIA
10 jours plus tard une femme nous
appelle elle se réclame de l'agence
mais la CIA utilise la reconnaissance
faciale
[Musique]
et voilà pour cette toute première
enquête de la cellule investigation de
France 24 enquête signée Jessica
lemazurier et roméo-langlois c'est la
fin de ce magazine merci de l'avoir
suivi à la semaine prochaine pour un
nouveau numéro de reporter sur France 24
[Musique]